[Music]
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
and i'm ryan nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists organizing
is well planned hoarding
thus the easiest way to organize your
stuff is to get rid of most of it no one
understands this better than
professional organizers amen the most
effective pros don't just organize your
things
they help you let go
today on this public minimal episode of
the minimalist podcast we're talking
about professional organizing with dr
julia roz founder of golden west
organizing then this thursday on the
minimalist private podcast the three of
us are going to talk about consumer
mausoleums you know all the places we
hide the dead things that no longer add
value to our lives
you can check that out at patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free because
advertisements suck
our first question today is from
facebook michelle has a question for us
how do you know when or if you should
hire a professional organizer and what
do you need to look for to get the most
for your money
julia first off thank you so much for
being here yeah well thank you for
having me this is a huge moment for me
to meet you both
uh as i was just sharing beforehand i've
done everything i could not to get
coveted to this moment so i've been in
hiding for a few weeks just so i could
be here that's amazing thanks so much
for i mean that's a commitment that's
like an over two year commitment so far
yes
yes so it is our honor to have you here
julia let's get to michelle's question
here so let's start off by talking what
is a professional organizer yeah so
you know i was reading through all of
those questions on facebook and i want
to define what it means to me because i
think professional organizers may define
themselves differently
so to me
professional organizing is all about
assessing our relationship with our
stuff
and for me i specifically do that in the
home although professional organizers
work in businesses they can work in
other types of settings as well but for
me organizing is all about evaluating
your relationship with your belongings
and making sense of it in your home and
and ultimately the most important part
to me is decluttering now others may
disagree with me but that is how i
define it myself i love it i love it in
a way so you're more of a professional
declutterer than an organizer you'll
hear me talk about this obviously i've
talked about the top of the show one way
that we often hide our hordes our
clutter is by really neatly organizing
it if i just get all the right
containers from the container store
right we got to go buy more things to
put our things in yeah and it's so cool
because what julia does is she's like
we're going to use what you have
and we're going to yeah i love that how
you take that approach with professional
organization so i always tell people
that i'm going to work with it that's my
approach however if they push me and
they say i really want this look then i
will
make that for them but it is never
something that is at the forefront of my
business yeah uh so i'm all about
reusing what we already have yeah uh and
space always opens up when you declutter
like when i tell people about my own
home which
after you know reading your books
watching your documentaries among so
many other things in minimalism that
were meaningful to me when i let go of
80 of my possessions all the space
opened up i didn't need to go to the
container store no it was just the space
was there yeah so my home may not be
very large but it feels very spacious to
me because of that choice i made and
that really informs how i approach
organizing as well so to talk to
michelle directly how does someone know
that they might need help from a
professional organizer yeah so um one
thing i'm asked often is like are you a
therapist too no i'm not a therapist
however i think the approach of looking
for a therapist is similar to finding an
organizer you know when you need
professional help when everything that
you have done isn't working for you
despite you trying in every way you can
so when you're seeking out a therapist
for whatever reason in your life it's
similar to looking for an organizer you
need some help because you just cannot
get yourself there and for most of the
people i work with they can't get
started that's the hardest part they
look at their stuff they shove it back
in the closet they just keep shutting
that door they cannot bring themselves
to get started and then when someone
like myself comes in i look at the mess
and all i see is what it can become all
i see is the potential
because of decluttering so if you feel
like you are not capable of taking that
step to start the decluttering process
that's the time to hire professional
help and really i recommend taking the
time to interview some people to see if
they're a good fit the same thing you
would do with a therapist you want it to
be someone you can trust someone that
you feel comfortable with because
ultimately you're showing someone a
stranger things you may not show your
family or your friends things that
you're too ashamed to show them so it
needs to be someone that you totally can
trust and know that they're not going to
judge you there you bring up a really
good point about shame quite often
there's a lot of shame with the stuff
ryan when you and i used to go out on
tour and we would sleep in on people's
couches or spare bedrooms or whatever we
were on a book tour and every time we
got to someone's house what is the first
thing they said to us i'm sorry
i'm trying to be a minimalist but you
know it's a little cluttery right now
like they're yeah trying to because
we're done minimalists like we're going
to come into their home and judge them
which we can only relate we cannot judge
i just apologized to mallory about the
state of my car this morning
immaculate for the record you guys you
know there are three people at this
table two of them are definitely not
perfect josh might be a little uh
immaculate because of his ocd he's
really he's definitely the closest
so let's answer the second part of
michelle's question here what do you
need to look for to get the most out of
your money because you are you're
spending more a resource and you're
actually spending more than one resource
you're spending money but then of course
you're spending time with that person
because here's the thing here's what i'm
looking for if i hire a professional
it's not just that they're going to come
and do
the work for me it's not like hiring a
plumber i need you to install a new
toilet for me yeah the problem isn't
simply the removal of the clutter anyone
can do that the problem is helping you
let go so that it doesn't re-accumulate
is that right yeah no absolutely i think
that many people want to hire someone so
that they will fix the problem just come
in and take everything out
but that isn't really the solution
ultimately you need to find someone who
is going to help you get to the root
cause of where the clutter is coming
from so that you have a plan in place
for when new things come in because they
always do we're always going to have
things coming into our home and it's a
matter of being able to
make decisions and moving forward and i
i see time and again that people just
have too much anxiety it's too many
decisions all the time so it's how are
you going to cope with those decisions
moving forward and ideally you hire
someone who helps come up with a plan
for you about what to do that you
actually think you can enact yeah let's
say like let's say someone is not ready
to let go and they're telling themselves
because i've seen this happen with
someone in my life that i don't want to
name or like you know call out but
they they were not ready to let go so
they were like i'm going to hire a
professional organizer and they're going
to help me
want to let go
is that is that the right reason to get
a
professional organizer like is it are
you able to kind of help people get
there and if so like how
yeah so i it's never an intervention
setting that i'm going in on i'm not
going in and uh against their will ever
so always people have chosen to bring me
in it's okay if they have a hard time
letting go though i'm not expecting
people to be gung-ho and it's really
easy otherwise they would have done it
themselves i wouldn't be there to begin
with but um i ultimately always respect
people's decisions on their possessions
even if i've 100 disagree with their
choices because of things like safety so
i've had people who wanted to hold on to
things that i did not think were safe
for their household because they were
arrested or expired and there were kids
or there were weapons things like that
but ultimately they still have to make
that choice however i am very good at
getting people to make good choices
moving forward because i repeat the
things that they say um i always remind
them of what their goal is why did you
bring me here why are you paying me to
be here what what brought you here to
begin with what do you want your home to
feel like yeah so often people will say
i feel so much stress i'm constantly
fighting with my spouse i just want to
get along you know like all of those
things so when they're having a hard
time letting go i remind them of why i'm
there you're like this good angel that
like sits on their shoulders
i mean they constantly have that that
clutter devil talking to them and you're
like no no no come on yeah
you can let go yeah exactly
this is great because like well no it's
just great because um what i'm hearing
you say is that if someone is out there
they're just like i'm not ready to let
go yeah i'm not ready to let go well
it's like we'll bring someone in maybe
they can give you a different
perspective on how to let go yeah and i
always talk with people on the phone or
facetime or even sometimes in person
depending how far away they live to see
if it's a good fit i think that's really
important if you're gonna work with
someone like this you need to have a
conversation with them you need to meet
them and make sure this seems like the
right fit and also be okay if it doesn't
if it doesn't work out kind of like the
therapist example if it's not a good fit
it's okay it doesn't mean you give up
you find the person who's the right fit
yeah i'll tell you i went through a lot
of therapists before i found like one or
two that i really trusted and it is like
it kind of makes you want to give up but
yeah but you and you you persevere you
like start interviewing more eventually
you'll find someone who like is on the
same page or same personality or
whatever a complimentary personality i
guess it's like if you went to a bunch
of different shoe stores and all they
have were size six shoes right you keep
trying them on over and over eventually
like you know what there are no shoes
that fit me well that's simply not true
you just have to find the shoe store
with the shoes that fit you and
fortunately for shoe stores they tend to
have the average sizes but
shopping around for a professional
whether it's a therapist or a
professional organizer you might have to
try on a few different ones to see which
one fits you let's move on to our
callers if you have a question or a
comment for our podcast give us a call
406-219-7839 or email a voice memo to
podcast at theminimalists.com
we have a question today from abel in
new jersey i have two storage units
filled with stuff
and i'm about to move into a new
apartment
what is the best way to start off my new
life and my new apartment with a
minimalist
point of view so julia this is another
problem that we have our homes become so
over abundant with stuff
that we seek out other areas to hide our
clutter now i don't know about abel
specifically maybe she is moving and
she's moved all of her things into
storage that's one way to do it and now
she's saying i want to extract the
things that add value to my life bring
it into my new minimalist home
so i'm avoiding the clutter up front and
bravo if that's the case or if you're
like many people who just store a lot of
things you're like my former self
i ran out of space in my basement my
attic my closet etc and so hey i know
what i'll do i'll spend 200 bucks a
month
on more
space
yeah now i will say this there are times
where it makes sense to have a storage
units yeah and so i'm not against
storage units by and large i mean it
doesn't make sense to be completely
expensive not binary yeah absolutely
right the storage units become a problem
when they allow us to hide even more
clutter when they lose their function
and we're holding on to more of our
horde i i need excess space for this
excess stuff for clutter if there is
clutter in the storage unit then it is a
problem well what is clutter clutter is
merely something that gets in the way it
could physically get in the way but
we've gotten it out of the way because
we put in a storage locker but now maybe
it's still getting in the way
financially you're spending more money
on that storage unit it's getting in the
way emotionally or psychologically
because you're thinking about that stuff
that's out there and so how would you
talk to someone like abel julia who
where she wants to start this new
minimalist life he's going into a new
home a blank slate
where does she start that's so exciting
first of all to begin with like when i
think about an empty space i get really
excited even when i work in homes that
are not empty i always empty the space
so we can reimagine what it can become
so i love that first of all and if it is
the first scenario that you were talking
about of
she's temporarily placing her belongings
there because she just moved i guess
then in that case this is the perfect
time to declutter um i wouldn't say i'm
anti-storage unit always but i am most
of the time if the purpose is just to
stuff clutter in there because you ran
out of room in your home
so i think moving is always a great time
to reevaluate your belongings and if she
really wants to start a minimalist home
in this new space let's try to not need
those storage units anymore i would
empty them see what she really needs and
everything else potentially should go
why keep those storage units any longer
i can think of so many other uses for
that money than storing that stuff um if
it i don't know if she also has a home
full of things on top of the storage
units too if that were the case i would
really ask her when was the last time
she ever needed to go into those storage
units to access any of those things
what are those types of things too it
may be things that are from
deceased relatives that she doesn't want
to deal with
and so this could be an opportunity to
work with an organizer to finally decide
i'm going to go through these things and
make some decisions on them this is
similar to my own personal story i
didn't have a storage unit but i had
been moving around apartments all over
la for many years and we didn't have a
garage we didn't have a storage unit
either so i had probably 10 boxes large
tubs of my grandmother's belongings she
died in 98. so it took me until 2020 to
let it go so i like sharing this because
it was not easy for me to let go either
somehow my boyfriend now husband allowed
me to carry this stuff everywhere and
have it shoved in our closets but
eventually um as i was decluttering my
belongings is the last thing that i
dealt with enough was enough and even
for me just having that open space in
the garage and a few of her items are
now displayed in my home office i see
them every day instead of having them
stuffed in the garage or the storage
unit it's such a better way to honor her
memory yeah and and everything so i
don't know the contents of what's in
that storage unit but i would want to
know more about that
and
this is the great a great opportunity
that's that's what i would say to
someone who wants to move into a new
home and potentially just let it all go
yeah it is a great opportunity i'm
thinking if if i was able i would
like bring over the bare minimum
and then like i would test that out for
30 days and like see how my life felt
and if i'm like oh man like i really
need some of that stuff in the storage
unit or what then i would like bring
some stuff in kind of slowly
um but that's a process like that's not
easy it's simple but it's not very easy
to do that because you're making trips
back and forth like moving sucks in
general let alone like if you have to
make trips back and forth from your
storage unit uh in the first three
months like that's gonna add more stress
so i think like yeah hiring a
professional organizer might be a good
idea for abel because maybe they can
kind of help her set it up a little bit
better rather than like spending months
of like going back and forth i don't
know
i uh personally i would go back and
forth but again that's i'm always i go
the extreme route all the time anyway
well yeah and this is you're forcing
yourself into something that any move is
an extreme thing right moving all of the
possessions you've accumulated over the
last 20 30 40 50 60 70 years
that's an extreme thing even if you
don't own much i you know i moved
recently and a friend texted me and she
was like hey how'd the move go i'm like
it's simple i'm a minimalist but it
doesn't mean that i enjoy doing it even
if you're a minimalist it's still a
relatively extreme thing to have to do
to fill your car with all of your
possessions
you can organize it and reorganize it
yeah it's extreme right so it wasn't as
ryan said it wasn't easy but it was
simple relatively speaking now what
you're talking about ryan is sort of a
hybrid version of your packing party
yeah really yeah where instead of
unpacking everything in your home you're
leaving in a storage unit you're going
to get it as you need it and it's
important to set up some boundaries
there and one of those boundaries might
be hey i'm going to bring things in
slowly over the course of 21 days or one
month or two months i wouldn't go much
further than that certainly not farther
than 90 days for me because then you
have the seasonality rule right and then
i would find what boundaries work for
you able you can download our free ebook
it's called 16 rules for living with
less it's the minimalist rule book over
at theminimalists.com rulebook we'll put
a link to that in the show notes as well
or if you'd like the audiobook version
of that you can find that there as well
but abel i'd be happy to send you a copy
of that i also want to send you a copy
of our book everything that remains
because this was really the story of me
and ryan we started letting go of the
excess moving and we moved across the
country into montana everything i own
fit into my car
even that oversized lamp i don't know
why i tried to cram the damn lamp in the
car
i ended up not even needing it yeah but
um the truth is that even then there
were things that i was able to start
letting go of and i only realized that
when i set up some boundaries in my life
we talk about some of those boundaries
and everything that remains so i i did
have a storage unit when we moved out to
montana i had storage unit back in
dayton ohio because i didn't know if we
were going to be in montana you know i
didn't know how long
so uh went back to ohio i think after
being in montana for a few months and i
was like oh like i just need to get rid
of this stuff so i like created a little
craigslist ad did a yard sale got as
much money as i could but you know doing
the math i'm bringing this up for able
like doing the math if i would have kept
that storage unit for a year or two it
would have been sunk cost at that point
i'd have spent more money on that
storage unit than what was actually in
that storage unit uh what was worth in
there so able i would look at that too
like how long have you had it what's all
that stuff monetarily worth if it is
worth something great go ahead and sell
it but you actually might be saving
money by just like getting rid of that
stuff i also think it matters whether
this is only these are only able's
possessions or other people's
possessions right because i don't ever
recommend letting go of things
without other people's consent we don't
know that information yeah right it may
be other people's things that would want
to have a say in this yeah so right so
be considerate of other people's
possessions
yeah it's so it's so important because i
often get told that too like people will
say can i i give you consent throw away
all my husband's things like i'm not
going to do that without their
permission because they're never going
to trust me and this is also just not
good for your marriage to do these
things right yeah so just wanted to
clarify that in my advice so she said
she's not a therapist but you do play a
really good therapist like you know i do
so much mediation i never thought i was
gonna have to do that between couples
constantly where they will be arguing in
front of me about stuff and i am that
neutral third party where i make things
you kind of like neutralize things for
them yeah i mean yeah when you you think
about it
money sex and stuff these are the three
things that couples argue about the most
the stuff
argument is rarely ever about the stuff
though as you start to uncover is like
there's usually something else behind
the bickering yeah the arguing about the
stuff the stuff is the physical
manifestation of our anxieties of our
discontent of our troubles and by
starting to let go of that stuff
together as a couple you start to
realize like oh
what i was actually upset with was not
you ryan it was my expectation of you
that's um it reminds me of jason and
jennifer kirkendall in our book love
people use things
and that in that chapter about stuff i
mean
they
basically found this common ground with
like decluttering but when they did that
it actually helped them to grow closer
together so they started with like the
actual stuff rather than like going to a
marriage counselor and like trying to
you know get on the same page and talk
out all their issues they were like
let's just work on this one thing
together and then it just kind of
snowballed from there and it made room
for the rest of their relationship for
improving their relationship not
improving by heaping on more things more
obligations more stress
more debt but subtracting those things
and now you actually experience the
spaciousness
to use julia's word the spaciousness of
the relationship able let me send you a
copy of everything that remains if you
want the audiobook version i think
you'll enjoy that if you enjoy our
podcast or if you want the book book or
the ebook version we're happy to send
you those as well ryan what time is it
you know what time it is it's time for
the lightning round where we answer your
text messages you can text your
questions your comments your smart
remarks too 937-202-4654
yes indeed now julia during the
lightning round this is where ryan and i
and our guests we try to answer
questions with a short shareable less
than 140 character response now we've
had like a week to prepare for this
you're being put on the spot so don't
worry about it we'll make it look really
pretty and post well
podcast sean well yeah i am decent with
twitter i will say that so i am used to
being succinct i'm going to put that on
my twitter profile
[Laughter]
oh my goodness
i'm going to tweet that later yeah i'll
put it i'm decent
at twitter see what people say yeah
that'll be great so we call these
minimal maximums we put them in the show
notes so people can copy and share our
pithy answers on social media if they
like and now thanks to our good friend
social jess you can find all of our
minimal maxims over at
minimalmaxims.com stephanie has a
question for us i struggle with constant
reorganization and feel compelled to
completely redo everything when i start
to declutter how can i find a system
that works for me
so julia we don't really have to give a
short 140 character answer but let's
talk about this because sometimes we
think about systems
and
if i just find the right system if i
just have the right organizing bin if i
purchase the right label gun to label
all of my clutter yeah then i will fix
it
how do you approach a question like
stephanie's yeah i this person may not
have decluttered enough that's my short
answer to this is that if they're still
struggling with putting together systems
and doing it over and over again then
they may not have completed the
decluttering process you don't need some
fancy bins you don't need some fancy
intricate system to be able to easily
find your things when you have the
appropriate amount of things for your
space and i think you know people
generally are always thinking about the
stuff first in the space second instead
of the reverse and for me when i made
that
change in my own thinking that's when
everything changed in my life too and so
i really try to push people with that
too of like let's think about where you
live how much space do you have here
she's probably not done decluttering if
she finds herself constantly trying to
reorganize and it may be a fear of
decluttering that's causing that to
happen it is scary and it does seem
easier to just go out and buy something
that's going to fix it
than to have to face the stuff which is
really facing yourself and your choices
that you've made yeah that leads into a
pithy answer for me is organizing is not
the solution
it is the problem
and thinking that if i just buy enough
bins if i just have a container store in
my closet
then everything will be fixed well no
it's just creating a bigger problem now
i'm hiding the excess i'm hiding the too
many shirts the too many pants the too
many pairs of shoes
too much jewelry too many pairs of under
or whatever it might be because i
haven't decluttered the stuff i haven't
even understood the why
and if you don't understand the why why
you're letting go of it i think that's
when we run into trouble like stephanie
you get rid of your excess stuff so
maybe you do take the decluttering far
enough for now but the closet the
kitchen cabinets the countertops they
become re-cluttered in the
not-too-distant future because we don't
understand why we are simplifying if you
understand why you understand the
outcome well it's not to have a cleaner
closet but it's oh i want more space i
want more calm i want more time i want
more financial freedom i want more bliss
i want more tranquility
i want less
chaos in my life
and if i figure that out then letting go
is simpler but also not bringing the
thing in
is just letting go in advance
[Music]
oh man um so josh reviews all my pithy
answers before i uh put him out into the
world so i sent him a pithy answer and
he was like that's great i totally
disagree with it
we don't have to agree i'm like i'm like
i'm like all right like that's all right
let's have a little disagreement but i
mean all right so my pithy answer is
this systems don't create habits actions
do
and if i could even take that a little
bit deeper i would say systems don't
create habits understanding does
because
once you understand the problem once you
get behind that why like the actions
become very apparent but a system isn't
going to take the action for you it's
really what i'm trying to say though
yeah yeah i don't want to derail too
much but i will say you know in
listening to this question and reading
some of the ones on facebook too i on
the one hand i think it's wonderful that
there is more of a mainstream
understanding of organizing because of
the popularity of certain netflix shows
right however it has led to people
believing that going out and buying is
really the answer right and i
the way that i approach organizing is so
different from what people see in those
shows sometimes people want me to
replicate that and i have to explain
that's not
the way i approach things too um
but what we see in those shows leads us
to believe that that is really the
solution is buying more because it is a
very maximal look at organizing it's not
minimalistic right it is beautiful to
look at i want to give complete credit
and i'm very impressed by that but it
isn't getting at that why that we were
all talking about of wh why are they
there i don't think you know i wonder if
there was a follow-up on those families
like we follow them a year later from
the things that we see on tv what does
it look like then were they able to
maintain it did they go and buy way more
what happened that's something that i
would be really curious to know but
again that's where i think that some
questions like this come from is this
again great that there's this mainstream
popularity of organizing understanding
what it is but at the other side of it
is i think it's leading people to
believe that buying is really the answer
to get
things right in their home yeah that's a
good i would love to see some follow-ups
you're right that would be interesting
where are they now julie what questions
do you ask people when you first start
working with them because
you help them get to that why not
through giving them answers but by
giving them questions yeah i usually
have them fill in the blank of you know
i want to get organized or i want to
declutter so i can or you know some
variation of that and
some people find it helpful to write
that down or take some time to think
about it i usually will just ask them
this is a question on the phone but
sometimes i'll have them say it as a
statement and i definitely take note of
this and remind them of it throughout
the time working together yeah um and
and you know as i'm talking with them i
do explain how my approach is different
from just buying more stuff
that's what got them there to begin with
and why they're calling me to begin with
um but yeah that's really central to my
approach is always understanding that
reason why they why i'm there what
caused them to call someone like me so
that i can help them not in the
immediate moment only but in the long
term yeah yeah you got to get that
emotional leverage like you have to find
something to like get them because once
you have that emotional leverage
like you can't not do something once you
have enough emotional leverage so this
like the the actions might lead to a
system like let's say you're an artist
and you do need some kind of catalogs of
like i got these paints and whatever
else like i like i know there are people
out there with professions who we all
got the best reasons to hold on to stuff
but like that's yeah
but
i brought a organized bin full of
reasons
but i mean yeah but it's like once you
have that emotional leverage you're
you're driven
to do something and then once you're
doing something then you might look at
systems to be like okay is there a more
you know reasonable approach or
streamline approach i don't know but and
that's why i ultimately said yesterday i
in fact i think what i said is i don't
completely i disagree with this no you
said i disagree and you're a jerk
that was a separate
with respect to that is sometimes we
the actions alone they don't really get
us anywhere because we don't understand
the why but ryan appending it with the
understanding totally agree with that
because a thorough understanding of the
why of doing what you want to do
will then
lead to all of the actions they'll
manifest on their own if you are
compelled enough to declutter your
closet i don't even need to give you
seven tips like some some of those
things might be helpful mechanically so
i'm not against them but i'm much more
interested in the why
why do you want to let go because if you
understand why you want to let go you'll
feel so compelled that the actions will
just happen
we've got so much more to talk about
including an amazing added value segment
coming up but malabama you have
something for us first here are some
voicemail comments and insights from our
listeners
hi my name is maz from cypress
california and i do have a tip um for
all of your clothes and your shoes that
you aren't in need of right now
i'm not sure if hospitals are accepting
it because of covet but um as a nurse i
know that when i discharge a lot of
homeless patients
we can't discharge them in the clothes
that they came in with you know
either they're dirty or you know um it's
just uh season wise it's just colder and
they don't have um thick warm clothing
so
if you are able to find a hospital that
is accepting donations and that would be
the best place since a lot of hospitals
we can't really discharge patient
patients and gowns
and we don't really have a lot of shoes
so that would be the best thing
hi josh and ryan my name is parker and
i'm from ventura california i just
wanted to offer up a really cool
resource for anyone who is a free
thinking individual and wants to become
more politically involved i myself find
it nearly impossible to truly understand
and take a stance on certain political
issues with the amount of polarizing
news and media that supports the
narrative there really is only the right
side or the left side
the organization i want to share is
called braver angels and it is a group
that seeks to make politics in the
united states less polarized through
thoughtful discussion and debates
it holds formal debates where people can
deliver speeches on extremely prevalent
issues there are time limits and
questions as well as alternating
positions throughout the whole debate it
is a truly refreshing and hopeful way to
experience politics so i highly
recommend it
all right y'all real quick for right
here right now here's
well two things going on in the life of
the minimalist a brand new month is
approaching ryan which is a
brand new opportunity to organize your
space but what's one way to do that by
getting rid of the excess stuff how do
you do that the 30-day minimalism game
you can download the free 30-day
minimalism game calendar at
theminimalists.com
game you partner up with a friend a
family member a co-worker at the
beginning of the month you decide first
day of the month i'm gonna get rid of
one item anyone can get rid of one item
right you can start anywhere your junk
drawer your attic your garage your
closet your office wherever you want to
start second day of the month you both
get rid of two items third day of the
month three items so forth and so on it
gets really difficult by day twelve oh i
have to get rid of a dozen things today
and 13 things tomorrow and 15 things two
days from now and so you keep letting go
throughout the month whoever goes the
longest wins if you both make it to the
end of the month then well you've gotten
rid of about 500 items each so i think
you've both won at that point the
minimalists.com slash game to download
the free
30-day minimalism game calendar you can
also share photos of your letting go
using the hashtag men's game
m-i-n-s-g-a-m-e
you can see tens of thousands of other
people who have played the game and you
can let go together also a quick
programming note for you
ryan our minimal and maximal episodes
starting next week will now be released
on mondays
with our new format that's with episode
351 if you didn't hear about
that new format we're also going to be
joined by our new co-host next week tk
coleman will be with us for complete
details you can go back and listen to
our phone conversation with tk on
episode
349 the one we had last week during the
right here right now segment for our
added value this week ryan
i've got a couple things so i'm starting
this new video series for how to write
better you and i went to a bookstore
this week it was outdoor used bookstore
i really like buying my books used
mainly because they're 50 cents each or
a dollar each or two bucks i don't have
to pay cover price right so i enjoy
buying used books but there's this
outdoor bookstore where i live and we
get to just go browse and you know one
of my favorite things the show up at a
bookstore and just pick a random book
off a shelf right and read the first
lines right you got first line battles
yes yeah it's like a rap battle but way
more literary yes
and
it's amazing how terrible
the writing can be sometimes sometimes
bad first lines can be how little
narrative urgency is there and so the
first book we're gonna do in that series
is bill clinton's book the series is
called bad writing
and the first one is gonna be from bill
clinton's memoir called my life
and the first line is really dry it's
like a calculus textbook or something
and i'm going to talk about how you can
make those lines better how you can take
that bad writing and very quickly turn
it into good writing and i'm also going
to compare it with some other great
writing now i don't know this person
gina sorrell but she has this book
called
mothers and other strangers
and bex picked this book out during our
first line battle and the first line
was amazing it made me want to in fact
it made becks buy this book
used and we're going to review that for
high quality writing what makes good
writing what makes it compelling we're
going to do that in this video series
you can head on over to
howtorightbetter.org
and find the youtube channel from there
we'll do regular bad writing videos give
you examples of bad writing while you're
there you can download the free ebook 15
ways to write better it's free for you
over at howtowritebetter.org
for our second added value ryan we have
to listen to a song
we were um
we were in nashville recently ryan
in june it's a month or so ago right
and it was during the full moon and
june's full moon is called the
strawberry moon
i didn't know that you know each month
has its own hunter's moon or the harvest
moon
in june it's a strawberry i mean we were
driving from franklin to nashville i
looked over
and there was this beautiful
strawberry colored moon coming up
over the horizon
and i looked down in our rental car
at the song that was playing
and it was caroline loveglow and it was
the title track to her new album which
is called
strawberry
so the song you're hearing in the
background right now is the opening
to
strawberry from
caroline loveglow or if you're watching
on youtube you can click somewhere near
my head and you can find the youtube
version of strawberry by the way big
thanks to dr julia roz for joining us
today you can check her website her
professional organizing business out
over at goldenwestorganizing.com
over there you can also find links to
all of her social media accounts all of
her updates are posted on instagram as
well we'll put a link to that in the
show notes by the way ryan we got a
bunch more surprise questions this week
like for those of us who have trust
issues with technology what are the
rules on how long to save important
paper documents what's the number one
thing professional organizers recommend
to prevent unnecessary items from coming
into my house
i can't afford expensive organizing
systems what are some cheaper
alternatives to keeping our things
organized plus a million more questions
for dr julia roz and the minimalists and
if you want to hear all that check out
the minimalist private podcast this week
visit patreon.com
the minimalist or click the link in the
description
to subscribe and get your personal link
so that our weekly private podcast plays
in your favorite podcast app and now
it's going to be on mondays we're
starting your week out with a little bit
of simplicity
starting next monday august 1st
by the way you also gain immediate
access to all of our archives our live
events
exclusive home tours and our private
community of thousands of open-minded
minimizers like you you can follow the
minimalists on tik-tok instagram
facebook and twitter at the minimalist
and if you want our podcast show notes
in your inbox sign up for our email list
over at theminimalists.com
on behalf of ryan nicodemus malabama
podcast sean jordan no more professor
sean social jess danny unknown
post-production peter m of the immigrant
and the rest of our team my name is
joshua fields milburn
if you leave here today with
just one message let it be this
love people
and use things
because the opposite never
works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next
time every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
that's just feeding your greed oh i bet
that you'll be fine
without it